good morning john happy esther day i
love you and here's a wonderful thing
this is getting easier and i have some
ideas about why if i try and look deeply
at why it's hard to say i love you to
you but easier to say it to
mom or catherine or oren
first of all the main thing is it's very
hard to say why we do or feel anything
humans are both very complicated and
very simple and the complicated parts
make it hard to see the simple parts i'm
going to try though the simplest answer
here is that saying i love you leaves
you very vulnerable it's like saying you
have the power to hurt me so
so much and like i'm not consciously
worried about you hurting me i'm not
even really i don't think subconsciously
worried about you hurting me but i think
i at one point in the past was brothers
can have competitive sometimes
antagonistic relationships that's
certainly been the case in the past for
us it's been a long time since our
relationship has been traditionally like
zero-sum competitive but to some extent
it once was and like that's in the
foundation right that's down there our
relationship is built over time and and
there's stuff that is there from the
whole time right it's all in there and i
think the way that that foundation has
continued to affect
however it has constructed itself over
time has been like you know it's about
collaboration it's about earning each
other's respect it's about being
impressed by each other that's a lot not
all of what our relationship has been
built on for a long time and i love you
doesn't really fit into the shape of
that relationship instead of i'm proud
of you i really like that thing that you
made it's i don't care what you do i
love you you are my brother and i will
always love you and care about it's a
completely different playing field and
it's a good playing field it's just not
where we have traditionally spent time
so it's uncomfortable so with all that
out there
here's why i think it might be getting
easier first we're getting older and
accomplishment and competition are just
more tempered i think the old playing
field seems a little less valuable this
new one seems a little more present
second maybe you have always been but i
am more aware of the fact that all of
this is temporary there's just a deeper
truer thing than like earning each
other's respect through accomplishment
and that thing is going to be more and
more important in the future and third
and god bless her for it esther made us
practice those of you who don't know
esther earl was a member of our
community early on and she died of
cancer in 2010 when her friends and
family asked how she would like her
birthday to be celebrated after she was
gone she said she wanted it to be like
a time to celebrate non-romantic love
like a valentine's day but for all the
other kinds of love pretty much the best
answer she possibly could have given the
first time you do anything new it's
gonna be hard and oftentimes if it's out
of
your typical experience it's hard the
fifth time but now it's been like 12
times and that
is a gift that's a good gift a couple of
yesterday updates tonight at eight pm
eastern time there's going to be a live
stream that will feature uh some people
from this star won't go out esther's
family and john and sarah and the animal
wonders folks and there's also this
beautiful t-shirt designed by karen
hallion all the proceeds from that go to
this star won't go out which is a
charity that helps families with sick
kids john i love you i'll see you on
tuesday